what's up my friend life is very good it
isn't be so one of the things that I
realized a lot of people talk about not
having enough time but really what I've
noticed it's not necessarily time it's
the rate limiting factor it's
inspiration passion fire energy that
seems to be what's the what's the
greatest limitation you seem to find the
same or do you think there's actual hard
time well I mean look hard time is real
right 24 hours a day I think it's real
but I think you're barking up the right
tree right which is a lot of people
asking how much I sleep so when they say
six to seven hours a lot of them get
confused you know they think that's too
much and I laugh because I always tell
them it's not what I'm doing other than
what I'm doing when I'm awake right it's
what you do in those 18 hours not what
you do in your rest time and I think
that for me I'm going 24/7 365 hard on
that 18 hours you know there's no time
to watch a funny video on YouTube or
things of that nature and yeah I think
it's a it's around determination and
passion and being excited and I couldn't
you know when I think back to being in
school how lazy I was how much I sucked
it was because I didn't believe in it
and so now I understand when people
don't believe in their job or what their
entrepreneurial venture is it makes
sense to me that they're not grinding
for me it's a foregone conclusion I
found my zone and I'm going to go as
hard as I can so yeah I think I think
they're both right you know I think we
all have relationships and you have
families and there's all these things
pulling at you but I always tell people
like I'm out of balance because if I
wasn't I would suffocate right like I
can't do the thing that you want me to
do that's currently politically correct
I can't do nine-to-five it's just not
who I am
I'd be unhappy and if I'm unhappy then
the whole thing is broken nobody's going
to do well if I'm in a bad spot right
now my family not my friends not my
employees not the people that rely on me
so yeah I can see where you're going
with that yeah I mean
when I'm when I'm on and fired up my
capacity is seems exponentially greater
of course it's like when it's a force
but I'm dragging myself through and just
doing it by some sense of having to do
it rather than that kind of fire are
there ways that you help people you know
get [ __ ] fired up for what happened
the only thing I think I do and people
whether they watch my videos I try to
suffocate out [ __ ]
and excuses right I feel like you've got
to attack the well not to think I don't
to get people tactic I don't want to
give them a thought or a five-step
program or a hint it's binary
either you're in the right place or
you're not and so I think the thing that
I'm trying to do is give people
permission to do things that they want
to be doing and what I've come to
realize through this journey as I've
started building audience is the
permission is not worrying about what
the inner circle thinks my big thing my
big revelation to myself is oh these
people are worried what their mom is
going to say they're worried what their
girlfriend's going to say they're
worried what their their husband's going
to say they're not doing things because
they're worried about being judged
Robert Greene in his book mastery calls
us the counter forces make sense hang
attention to these things in your inner
circle that are going to drive you based
on their own spheres and their own
projection into something that you
shouldn't do my father wanted me to be a
[ __ ] bond analyzer laughing like some
some work in some Goldman Sachs idea you
know which would have been an absolute
derailment in my career fortunately you
know I had enough of my own resolve and
personal practices I was able to avoid
that counter force but for some people
those can be too strong and if they
don't shed those things I think that's
what I'm trying to give I'm trying to be
everybody shield to their inner circle
by blaming me for it I'm on this new
kick like I just made a video this
morning outside the airport point to
this video and let me take the [ __ ]
everybody in the comments like grandma
come tell me I'm a dick face you know
like it's fine like I can handle it I'm
trying to get people permission so I
think I think the one thing I'm trying
to figure out is how to communicate
through video through audio
the written word how do I communicate
the at-bat that I want everybody to have
because when you're happy you start
getting into a funny place that I would
call guilt I'm in a funny place
I almost feel so grateful and so guilty
that I'm doing this not only because I'm
narcissistic and I like the attention
because that's real I like the attention
that's real but the impacts insane I
mean if anybody could have the drug that
I'm addicted to which is the hundred
emails a week of people telling you that
their life is better because of you and
that you've figured out that the way you
communicate hits people well now I'm
like oh crap I have this you know it's
like the comic book thing like with
great power there's great responsibility
like okay if I've got a style to
manipulate people most people go down a
bad path
but I've got lucky I got great parents
and great DNA so let me get to the truth
and the truth is your mom's [ __ ] you
up and so like if I can get in there and
penetrate and say hey point to me you
know I'm an immigrant so every Asian
Indian Eastern European Latino immigrant
you know parents are pushing education
and I'm out there getting D's and F's
and doing my thing
and they're like can I and I love it
what sometimes people email me they're
like can you make a video for my dad or
like yep hello mr. cazuca [ __ ] you like
just you know it's like of course yes
James
no no means means we're going to be that
I mean our general listen let's remember
what's going to happen we've lived
through nine good years of an economy
shits about to hit the fan and you know
what happens when [ __ ] hits the fan I
say shits about to hit the fan next year
the next year tomorrow three years from
now
it's bull market you know they're you
know they've got another 100 percent so
as soon as it happens you know what's
going to happen everybody goes to
defense know everybody is an
entrepreneur now it's really great to be
an entrepreneur it's really cool let me
give you the steps you need to do you
need to open an Instagram account and in
your bio you put CEO
like you know super super-great you know
I love how everybody's like I'm an
entrepreneur I'm an entrepreneur that's
like me saying on the basketball player
there's you know there's a difference
between being paid to be a professional
basketball player and doing the [ __ ]
that you and I did a couple weeks ago in
the gym where we were huffing and
puffing right being an entrepreneur is
awesome and I want everybody to try it
or be romanced by it but don't be
delusional
there's only a few that actually win at
the levels that everybody you know the
watch is in the private jets are for a
small group and then there's only
another group that's bigger that can
actually afford to live their lives that
way and you have to be mentally strong
it's scary it's by yourself I'm dying to
see what happens when [ __ ] hits the fan
because I want to first see who's really
an entrepreneur who's not you know who's
willing to live in a studio apartment
after that they have to sell their fancy
LA house because they overextended
themselves and now are they going to go
work at Bank of America or are they
going to live super humbly in a studio
with four of their homies instead of
that awesome place with all the bikinis
at the you know pool like like where you
know and so who's going to grind and so
I think that a lot of people look at
entrepreneurship and this alternative
that you and I were just talking about
as a fun great thing it has been I'm
just worried it's not self-sustaining I
know so many people that look like
they're winning but they're not because
if their cash flow stops which oh by the
way for 90 percent of them is raising
capital yeah yeah right I mean like
people aren't making money when the tie
retracts as it will that capital all of
a sudden your [ __ ] t-shirt company is
not going to be the next supreme right
yeah I mean the pinch it seems like
every successful entrepreneur talks it
has that pinch moment that pinch moment
where the forces of resistance will
mount up and then they test you to see
if you're really for real and then what
happens is very simply whether it's for
real or you got it
it's just simple I couldn't breathe
doing anything else yeah like there's no
old term I don't want to anything I
don't want a house in a car and another
a boat
I just want to play the game the luxury
of no choice I mean that was something
that the Spartans entrained in their
troops right I mean there was never give
up never surrendered it wasn't even an
option it didn't even play in their mind
because when you have that quit as an
option when that's not part of your
ethos that you don't quit or that's not
part of who you are then you'll torture
yourself with that thought alone and
then as we were talking earlier that
will slow you down you know the more
that your mind can go should I should
make sure that when you're a clear yes
this is going to happen it's way easier
to move you know what's funny you look
funny it's listening to carefully yes
it's going to happen is something I'm
that I've been thinking a lot about
which is my definition what I just said
is I don't know if it's going to happen
or not it's just I don't
I'd much rather run my own businesses
and make 80,000 a year then not and make
a million a year I just can't breathe
it's all I've ever known that's the
thing I don't know how many people right
now they call themselves founder CEO and
entrepreneur if I said there's two
million a year being a banker right or
here's 86,000 slinging your hats and
t-shirts I just think most of them take
the two million at least the ones I've
been coming across the last three or
four years that's the difference when I
was 29 28 and building this big liquor
store in New Jersey I was making 47
thousand dollars a year I didn't have
anything cool I wasn't in the clubs in
New York City my friends who were
working at Wall Street and Goldman and
all those things or consulting or other
things they were making 150 200 thousand
and they were right and I was happy too
many people are envious right now the
entrepreneur is the thing that so many
MD and I'm scared that when the market
corrects people can be lost I'm actually
you know this whole last rant last 5-6
minutes I just want to clarify it I'm
not angry I'm worried I'm worried
because a lot of these kids I have hard
for and they and they aren't on they're
not going to be successful entrepreneurs
well there's a
kind of factor that will come into play
you know a lot of if you look at
evolutionary biologists they'll talk
about the genetic bottleneck theory like
some macro of that will happen a volcano
will go off foliage will die plant you
know animal species will decrease and
then that Windows the human population
down to the strongest the savviest the
most creative and then those people
start collaborating and working together
in the case of evolutionary biology they
start breeding and that advances the
human race in some respects this you
know tide should it come will actually
focus the people who are really totally
great clear out this happened then
what's going to come next at the next
boom is going to be another evolution
hundred percent by the way I'm pumped
I'm worried because I have feelings for
twenty six-year-old Charlie who's a nice
kid I'm thrilled because the game of the
game the market is the market and that's
the way it should be and then I'm
selfishly thrilled because I built two
businesses during [ __ ] times and I'm
more comfortable being a wartime general
than anything else I want carnage I want
to be forced into restructuring my
company I want to be crappy and evolved
through the minefields I don't like all
this you know c-minus players thinking
they're legit and enjoying the fruits of
the game that's when I feel shit's
broken yeah or even I mean even for me
there's a sense oh there's a sense of
bloating that can come when the
successes to my trip restraint where I
have projects that are going they're
probably I should cut if I grew the drop
that I needed to and that feeling the
austerity of having the world collapsed
down upon you you know certain people
with that stoic mentality you see that
force of resistance say oh great there's
a [ __ ] dragon now the hero can
come out you know without a dragon there
are no heroes right like your own yeah I
mean look now this is why I disrespect
anybody who's a Patriots fan that
doesn't live in Boston or from Boston
that's just the quickest tell that
you're not a hero that's the quickest
tell that you need some other force to
give you self-esteem
like I love losing I love being a Jets
and mixed fan I love the climb
I need that dragon all the time I
manifest it I'm so [ __ ] up I make up
fake problems just because it's not
interesting yeah I mean it when I want
in the wine game I moved to this
Bing and like my biggest fear is that
vaynermedia is becoming the clear-cut
winner of this new digital social agency
and I'm like [ __ ] I can even feel it in
my body already I'm like this is bad
because once everybody succumbs to this
truth then it's not fun anymore
than I've got to find a different dragon
well sounds like you probably have a lot
of dragons that you're looking at there
they're small they're sitting underneath
your middle earth but you're going to
come steal like jewels but you know what
this is what's interesting to me this is
the thing I'm trying to dissect who's in
it because they're in it and who's in it
because it's the trend and let's not get
it twisted there's an enormous amount of
people listening even for this podcast
right now that are in it because it's on
trend and by the way it's easy you can
say you're a rapper or an athlete but
you can easily see that you're not by
the actions of that entrepreneurship is
hidden entrepreneurship is kind of like
you say it on your gram account and then
you kind of can look the part you can go
to the parties you can go to the
conference's like you can trick it way
more than a lot of other things and and
so I'm saying this very carefully listen
to me if you know deep down that you're
being exposed by this rant here's a
smart move before the world collapses go
figure out who you think is actually
going to survive that who are the
wartime generals let me remind a lot of
you the 84th employee at Facebook is
going to make much more money than the
founder of almost every company that's
going to be invented over the next five
decades so the one advantage is the
access to these winners that you've
never seen before so if you are
listening right now and saying [ __ ] you
Gary like I got this I'm going to do it
then do it stick it to my face I can't
wait to get the email from you
five six seven eight years now but if
you're listening and saying true because
I wasn't into being a businessman or
woman when I was a junior in high school
right I was going to be this I was going
to be an architect I was going to go to
Harvard I was going to be a banker if
that's you give a real thought to this
because
we've seen this in 2001 and 2008 [ __ ] is
very ugly and it's a 10 year 7 year five
years step back or you could take
advantage of the window we're in right
now and take advantage of the fruitful
times and the access to these a plus
generals and I would jump on those boats
if I were you yeah well uh what is the
place for that I think it's cool
internally I think it's [ __ ] externally
like like you're losing too much when
you fake it to you make it with the a
players of the universe like nobody's
tricking me like I know you bought your
fans your engagement blows like you know
like like like I I think fake it to you
make it look being confident you will up
and me like I'm 23 I'm starting a sock
company and I'm going to win that's
different than saying I'm already
winning or this stand the other thing or
the event of authenticity
any people like hey Gary I'm friends
with your boy did I check yes I'm like
yo you keep friends with this kid like
he rolled up at me at South paw like I
think faking to you make it fake users
and makes you use with winners so really
what you're saying is instead of fake it
till you make it
believe in your hundred percent in
yourself portray that belief because
that's authentic that's real because now
we're in an age where inauthenticity is
going to get us but it's going to get
exposed I'm not running around saying
I'm part own to the Jets and soon I'm
just going to buy the rest I'm saying I
want to try to buy the Jets I'm gonna
buy the Jets that's different but you
have a lot of people they're just like
getting into fake news and like really
like just making up [ __ ] and saying like
oh your boy you know he confirmed that
he's going to be an investor like again
people the amount of kids that have
ruined their brand with so many of the
winners that I know is staggering to me
and that has been during good times it's
going to get way worse so I don't know I
think thank you to your make it
internally you know trick yourself that
you got it that's good
I like the delusional thing yes yes yes
the line faith blind faith but when you
start putting that out to the world
now you're fronting now you're
bullshitting and you're losing equity
with the people that you want it again I
always tell people you're tricking
users like the kids that are getting
tricked and you're the man and you're
the woman and like you're winning like
that you know that's how who you want to
be winning over and then you come to the
big leagues and you get exposed and then
that trickles I mean it's unbeliev by
how much people talk at the levels that
you want to be at and you need to be
careful when you come into those circles
one of the other motivational factors
that you touched on is the impact that
you're having on other people and
something when I coach other people too
I say you can get exhausted if all
you're doing is focused on yourself if
you're focused on what your mission will
do to the things that you love if you
clean yourself but beyond yourself as
well you'll have a lot more fire and a
lot more passion to do it I think it's
an important part of the why I think a
lot of people would be stunned how how
much money I leave on the table every
day because my number one KPI is how
many people show up to my funeral the
end period on the story and there's
nothing even remotely close the whole
ambition for the New York Jets
is a distant second and all the
short-term stuff got a lot of the Vayner
sports guys here people people I meet on
the street about Boehner sports like
they're like I don't think people
understand like I I don't care about
that like I really don't give a [ __ ]
about money and now person listening is
like Oh easy for you to say no you've
got to go look at what my life was like
when I was building my library I didn't
care either you know 24 25 26 27 28
year-old dudes when they built a 45
million dollar business don't tend to
pay themselves $40,000 they don't
because they know that those dollars can
get them what they want girls fun I am
obsessed with my legacy which means I'm
trying to give more than I'm taking on a
daily basis plus I know I'm good enough
to get mine without taking from somebody
else so I'm running marathon my only
vulnerability my kryptonite is being
regretful in my 7 years or 80s when I
have less than a tank and I might say oh
[ __ ] I left too much on a table that's
something I think a lot about I I think
a lot about being 8090 and saying mmm
you know it wouldn't have been a bad
idea to take a little more
but I'm hopeful that doesn't transpire
because I think so far I feel very
confident that both are going to get
theirs right I'm going to get mine and
the people that interact with me are
going to get theirs from me and I think
that has a lot to do with why I put out
so much content most of you believe that
you want to do business with and work
with they're going to have that innate
sense of if you give they're going to
feel you know compelled to give back we
had that conversation about an influence
and meetup just now it's a universal law
that most people feel and so if you
abide by and believe in that law and
treat people that way give first let me
just try let me give everybody who's
listening right now the one little piece
that makes that system work and it's a
rare trait I don't know if you can
develop it but if you can you should
here's the big one that's exactly right
my man comma when somebody lets you down
you can't spend a second on it if you're
gonna give and you're going to expect
nothing in return I've got big news for
you a lot of people are going to give
you nothing in return you have to be
mentally in a place it's insane to me
how little somebody lets me down I help
somebody get into a deal it was closed I
reopened the deal got them in they made
millions of dollars on a $50,000
investment couple years later my second
book came out I said yo bro can you buy
a bunch of just trying to sell as many
as possible dude it had nothing for me
I made a millions of dollars other
people I met one time one time and they
were buying hundreds everybody's
different but I would tell you it was
stunning to me how much it didn't bother
me I took no cuz I knew I could tell
this story one day right and I knew that
it would be a great lesson but it it was
I was unfazed because that's just the
way it is you can't you can't live by
giving without expecting anything in
return and then knowing I always tell
people karma is practical there shit's
practical like do the right thing it's
just going to work out especially what
people are said you know what I prefer I
like doing the right thing and actually
having them say good things about me
behind my back even if I don't get what
looks like the deal in front of me cuz
like this long
and so yeah man I agree with you but for
example my dad the other way my dad
could never play that game he's so good
he's up he's so let down by people his
he wants his employees to care more
about his liquor store than he does it's
insane I tell him I'm like dad they
would have worked for you if they liked
it he's not practical about it and I
struggle with it and I and I try to get
him there but this is the hardwiring
thing for me my whole game works because
I expect nothing and I mean nothing from
nobody zero not my mom not my dad the
biggest reason I went to my family
liquor store business I didn't want to
go into it because I didn't want people
say oh your dad had a liquor store I did
it because I wanted to pay back the dues
that my parents did by coming to America
and making us a middle-class family by
having a local liquor store reciprocity
reciprocity at work so I think that um
yeah man I'm a big buyer of that I'm
just worried a lot of people on the
other line
don't understand you've got to check
your feelings at the door and if you're
giving without expectation that means
pay attention without expectations I
think that's incredibly important
because when you go the other way then
you start to get let down by people and
then that starts or to erode your
mission to help other people because
you'll start looking you'll take a
specific case example someone will do
something [ __ ] up to you and you'll be
like you put yet that people are [ __ ]
up right rather than oh this person made
a mistake because I recycle I tell all
my homies I'm like that's cuz you're a
loser
I tell them that I go you're a losing
player if you need somebody else to do
something for you to get yours you're
already broken I was telling you in
there like in everything I do nobody can
have leverage and that's how my whole
life is nobody's got leverage over me
because I just don't want to live that
way like why like why put yourself in
that position if you're good enough you
don't need it and everybody talks a big
game and then they need somebody else to
do something to have them win I just
don't believe in that we all need people
we need help we need breaks we need luck
I believe in all that [ __ ] like I hate
when people think there's of course
there's moments and I like the internet
came along at the right time for me
right like I don't know like is that
luck of that timing we all have that but
to put yourself in a position when you
rely on somebody else or worse
and this is the one that drives me
batshit crazy the amount of people that
want to do nice things for me because
then they want to hold it over me for
something else you can taste that [ __ ]
from a mile away
like I know you're trying to do that and
the funniest thing people are crazy to
people like hey I'll give you this free
t-shirt all right now you you should
invest a million dollars into my
business like they're not even like
normal trades right well the one that I
love if people say they don't buy me a
cup of coffee yeah I'm gonna buy you
dinner I'm like cool I'm like you better
buy [ __ ] ten restaurants you can make
coffee like unlimited supply a cup I
have a cake on tap am I like what are
you offering me you know clicking off
quickest way to get a delete out of my
inbox and it happens 15 times a day
the titled I'm going to help you buy the
New York Jets that's the quickest tell
that you're not yeah yeah that makes
perfect sense
one of the things that I noticed with
you that that's done business a lot of a
lot of people with big podcasts and big
followings and and and one thing I
notice with you is you're a believer
like I am and leaving meat on the bone
and I've been surprised with dealings
with other people and usually those
dealings fall through when they're
unwilling to leave they just carve it to
the very precipice where it's just at
that 50 50 maybe you both they're taking
a little lost kind of kind of spot and
it just it boggles my mind why they have
to push it there when they when there is
abundance when there's plenty of meat
for both sides but they push it to that
infinite level and in that quick
conversation with you it was an easy
immediate yes because it was recognizing
abundance and saying hey let's both eat
well you know it was funny about that
was we went right to the punchline right
I was like look this matters to me I
know what matters to you and like yeah
man yeah I mean look I just genuinely
believe in 5149 I'm desperate to try to
do more for the other person I'll be
honest with you I think it's leverage
yeah I like it I like being in that
power position I don't want to be on the
hook for something and so it just works
on so many ways number one I don't have
to think about it imagine having to
think about owing people [ __ ] that's
exhausting number two the person feels
great to your point even the biggest
guests are always trying to carve too
much for themselves so people can taste
it
so you took note of that right so then
you already feel good it makes it easy
it's like light on your chest
like it's just right it's recognizing
the long game too because I don't know
when they carve out a little bit extra
for you in the immediate but in the long
term you know it just leaves that sour
taste and it allows the grounds for that
relationship to to dissipate you said
something to just render something that
I the other thing is I try not to Cham
with people that I don't think are going
to be there at the finish line so if I
already think you're going to be a
winner like it makes so much more sense
to have a 53 year relationship you know
it's funny I don't if you guys watch all
these documentaries or like stuff but I
was so I always I'm so so fascinated
when two guys two gals are sitting there
like we've known each other for 62 years
ready to see that thing I'm always into
that like every time I'm an optimist
every time I meet some money I'm
thinking forever I'm thinking one of the
two of us has come into the other
person's funeral like I think that way
and so yeah I'm trying to build
relationships yeah I think that's such a
key because some people you know I
describe it with the analogy the
difference between a squirrel and a bear
right a squirrel is out trying to get as
many nuts as you can in the analogy for
humans that's money trying to get as
much as many nuts as they can't bury it
put it in your bank account bury it in a
hole in the squirrel case and hope that
no animal comes and digs it up the taxes
the lawyers yep whatever the erosion and
then there's the bear that consumes as
much as they can and leaves it on its
body and to me being the bear means
forging these connections if then it's
like Willie Nelson when Willie Nelson
ran out of money in the [ __ ] IRS went
to go take his ranch or take everything
he had so many good connections within a
day
people are like egg Willie will take
care of your ranch famous it's like no
problem because he forged something that
was beyond that someone no one could
take they couldn't take that away from
him just like you can't take the Bears
fat away from them you know it's not
burying money in little holes it's
building something that's a part of you
and those are the connections that you
form no matter if on it got [ __ ]
crushed you know tomorrow I'll be fine
because I've done you know I've done
right by absolutely every person
I've given I've given my time my heart
my services in every relation so we
could just start something out to be on
it too but what I'm worried about is
there's a lot of people listening right
now and saying okay easy for you guys to
say and what I always tell these kids is
you don't understand that's how we got
to that place you know like everyone is
like easy for you easy for you like I
just I'm just fascinated by people's
lack of patience like I didn't even you
know and I know we live in a social
media world and everybody's getting all
these things flashed at them but it's
crazy I'll never forget the day I
started working full-time in the liquor
store was 22 and I remember saying to
myself literally literally the first day
like I've been working the source for
eight years since I was 14 but this is
it I'm done with college I actually
worked a little few hours when I drove
home from college my last day but the
next day was the first day it was so
weird I hated school my whole life and I
was it like I walked into the liquor
store and I never had to go to school
again it was like crazy it was the best
day of my life
and I'll never forget I remember saying
okay I'm not going to say a word for the
next decade
I'm not going to talk to my friends this
is real and I didn't my high school
college friends are very weirded out by
me I like I like just went in the cocoon
and I just worked every minute and I
need to think about popping out until I
was 32 not a word not a peep not a party
nothing and now I've got kids emailing
me like Gary thank you so much I love
your videos you inspire me
when I'm super down I almost gave up
last week you have been doing my new
business for about four months then I
hit a real wall and like this is [ __ ]
bad with you four months yep you even
hit a wall
you mean gotten out the gate you you're
not even you're not even in the car
you're like still sleep in your bed I
just really want to push patients and
the long game all this relationship talk
you and I have been doing squirrel bear
all that [ __ ] it's all long game you're
either playing for life or you're
playing for the few minutes ahead of you
and again this keeps going back over and
over in my mind to what other people
think too many people right now I mean
social media has become the place where
everybody is a PR agent of them
sells let's call it what it is right I
just said there's a bunch of dudes in
here that's the first big head not
everybody just had not your PR in
yourself I get it
you know like I get people want you know
to hook up and to have fun I get
everything I get it but it is creating
ungodly short-term behavior which is not
allowing people to really win the game I
was part of the early phase of this
right I started a youtube show four
months after YouTube came out there was
nobody there like there was no social
media there was myspace but if you
remember people went to your wall right
it was a different loop so yeah man I
just had like one comment like weird you
know like like like there was you know
and now what's happening is not only are
we addicted to the feedback but we're
crippled I mean it's unbelievable to me
to watch my friends get 83 good comments
and one person says they're fat or
they're dumb or stupid and they dwell
and they dwell on this and this is why I
keep getting back to this thought of how
do you get insular and know what you're
doing for yourself for yourself you know
Ivan Drago right last seen like he loses
and he's like yeah he's saying I do this
for myself
not for the [ __ ] premiere not for the
Soviet Union I was in the ring for
myself and it's a funny scene I was born
in Russia
I love the Rocky movies I love America
way more than the Soviet Union so maybe
it sticks with me but there's something
about that scene right everybody knows
Drago for the famous scene like I'll
break you for me it was when he was in
the ring is like for myself and that's
how I feel like I just don't give a [ __ ]
what anybody thinks and I mean not my
kids not my parents not my wife now I
equally care so much of how they view me
and what they think of me it's pulling
from opposite directions but you got to
start with yourself because when you're
actually allowing other people to get in
you're vulnerable I remember the first
time I kind of burst onto the public
scene went on Rogan podcast and head on
it and started to attract some negative
feedback yeah really in my life I've
lived away with I got very little of
that you know and I was exposed to very
little of that and this kind of wash of
it was very challenging for me so I
reached out to my
homey bode miller at the time and know
he for people who don't know in the
Torino Olympics he was supposed to wear
news everything yeah and he did what he
does but he enjoys his life he's keys
right but people took that as he wasn't
taking it serious Jericho he had they
have some kind of rating system and in
sports agencies and he actually had a
lower rating than oj after he [ __ ]
finished his trial right so life people
he was getting death threats yeah really
i remember him like man how did you deal
with these like listen my whole life the
only thing I care about is my is my
judgment of myself did I give it my best
did I do what I know I can do because
there's going to be people who
compliment you when you don't deserve it
and there's going to be people who you
know tear you down when you don't
deserve it but if you know only you know
really what you committed and then judge
yourself accordingly to that let me we
get a little practical here because I
think you and I have similar vibes and
so that can get very heady right it's
really up in the cloud and by the way
that's the punchline like this is a
mental game like there's just nothing
else but let me get real practical let
me give you a couple things that I
really want to leave people with stuff
that you know I've been putting out a
lot of [ __ ] for the last five or six
years and I'm starting to see the themes
of what's actually working here's a big
one if you're not feeling it find new
friends I'm being dead serious about
this this one is real big for me who you
hang out with is a huge young again
these are all trying true things right
we've heard the you're the whatever of
the five friends you spent like that's
real that's that one put in the bank
like if you're not feeling it you need
to go to meetup.com and go to ten
meetups of people that are hungry like
it's unbelievable what happened to me
when I got into the Silicon Valley world
and started meeting like Mark Zuckerberg
and like F Williams and sock and like
Travis like it changed my life this town
actually it's fun for me to tell the
story here South by Southwest 2007
changed my life because I hung out I
forced myself to go to a web 2.0 which
later became social media the current
state of the internet conference South
by Southwest and I was looking at all
these kids and by the way this is when
tech wasn't cool
straight [ __ ] nerds but they were
trying to change it they weren't here
for kicks and giggles they weren't here
to
hook up they were here to like change
the world like I'm going to build a
product that is going to be in every
single person's hand like and they have
like the Twitter's and Facebook's the
ubers they did and and it was biggest
impact in my career and it's something I
think a lot about now
so anyway real practical if you feel
motivated by this conversation or you're
intrigued by it add one new winner
friend like you know what I mean had one
new winner friend and cut one loser
friend like yeah I know he's been your
boy since fourth grade but he sits at
home and [ __ ] smokes weed and plays
2k all day like you can only love them
so much I always challenge people to
because everybody will do that with
their romantic interest right they're
always hunting and pursuing and they got
online dating apps and they're looking
for this like intellectual relation like
to the right but but with friends it's
just like oh yeah it's just like it's
default it's who your aims were you
never cut anyone like you'll break up
with a girl she's bad with you but a
friend you feel like you can't break up
with a friend you know it's just weird
paradigm where it's like oh yeah they're
just my friends if estimates I was with
a badass being entrepreneur the other
day and she's such a ninja she [ __ ]
does it and it's changed her life and
the way she broke it down I was like
okay like I just believe in it I believe
it so anyway there you know again we're
pontificating high level [ __ ] your brain
might not be there here's something real
go home
cut one cut your leisure as your friend
and go find a winner friend go like go
somewhere go somewhere like go to like
go go to meetup.com go to a Facebook
group join some [ __ ] DM the 800 people
that you think are make sure they're not
bullshitting they're like doing what you
want and just make one new friend I see
it like dirac like he's right like it's
unbelievable to watch my team like they
get faster to get smarter they get more
confident right it's real man it's real
confidence and like hunger gets passed
on to each other
it's like Team Dynamics it's why like a
great player that sucks [ __ ] can [ __ ] a
team up like go audit your circle add
one more winner decrease one more loser
and you can still do it
you don't have to be rude to that person
but you just have to have the discretion
you have to be you know your own best
coach you know you have to put yourself
in position to win and just you know do
it's not breaking up it's like you know
I just can't come over four times a week
like I know I don't want to be on the
fifth [ __ ] softball team like for
softball teams enough location in
general by the way let's get the
sunshine or good like that's your life
is that more girly or be back I just
don't complain my big I had like I think
about this in both ways you you want
more money and more stuff work work more
like like work more but like then I'm
the flip I have all these friends
they're like doing great crushing
millions of dollars tens of millions of
dollars and they'll sit there and be
like oh man like I wish I spent I wish I
had more time for my kids I'm like you
have 38 million dollars in cash in your
bank I'm like don't [ __ ] PR me go and
[ __ ] spend time with your kids
yeah like I just I just don't like
complaining like you can do anything you
go to you can order 365 birthdays a year
you could be on 37 softball teams you
can make $4 you can make 4 trillion
dollars my big thing is don't complain
you're in control only two people that
I've been saying this a lot
I believe in it there's only two groups
of people that listen to you complaining
a the ones that have to your mom right
the two or three closest relatives you
have and then be your other loser
friends right like the other ones again
the man like yeah trumps holding me back
yeah Obama's holding me back yeah they
comfortable because then they don't have
to put themselves out there people don't
want to take responsibility I love that
everything's my fault
anything happens at vaynermedia that's
broken my fault you know why I hired the
person yeah like yeah I get it that
Sally's a [ __ ] guess what I hired
her and that's any leader any leader any
leader steps up and says okay my guy and
not for kicks and giggles not cuz it
looks good not cuz it sounds fun on a
podcast because it's true yeah I
understand it's a beautiful rapper with
you son man
I'm looking forward to a lot of cool
things we're gonna create a future I
can't wait wish everybody good health
Sammy
much love
[Music]